j'accueille à présent bertrand charles
bonsoir à vous c'est un des responsables
de la smb rugby il s montigny le
bretonneux vous venez ce soir nous
parler de deux matches n'ont pas de
montigny le bretonneux ni de la section
féminine d'ailleurs que vous pilotez
mais plutôt de deux rencontres du stade
français en reichel et crabos ce sont
les catégories des plus jeunes moins de
19 ans et moins de 21 ans et ses deux
rencontres vont se dérouler dimanche au
stade de la couldre à montigny le
bretonneux
pourquoi de tels matches à montigny le
bretonneux le stade français qui va
venir évoluer ne pouvait pas recevoir
sur son propre terrain en fait le stade
français au niveau
pardon infrastructures pour les jeunes
est assez pauvre en terrain de qualité
donc est toujours à la recherche de
terrains donc ce sadique de jeunes ou
même des équipes féminines du stade
français en fait je joue très rarement à
vaucresson qui est le pôle jeunes du
stade français et cherchent toujours à
jouer à l'extérieur donc le stade
français viendra évolué à montigny le
bretonneux et montigny-le-bretonneux
était candidat vous candidatez justement
les différentes communes un petit peu
souhaite accueillir ces différentes
rencontres même si on n'est pas sur les
seniors ce sont les catégories des plus
jeunes mais ça reste le stade français
en fait on a été approché par le stade
français et on a aussi un jeune de chez
nous qui maintenant on joue depuis trois
ans au stade français dans cette es
gorille crabos donc la catégorie des
moins de 19 ans voila j'aimerais en
parler d'ailleurs de lui de lui tout à
l'heure on va peut être préciser un
vraiment c'est catégorie reichel et
crabos à leur échelle c'est la
compétition rugby à 15 des moins de 21
ans du nom d'un ancien joueur de la fin
des années 1800 d'ailleurs et puis
crabos et les moins de 19 ans du nom de
rené crabos un joueur des années 20
c'est de compétition ces deux
championnats sont sont assez relevé on y
trouve des futures vedettes des futurs
talents qui évolueront en seniors et
peut-être dans le top 14 plus tard oui
tout à fait puisque généralement c'est
en fait l'antichambre des équipes
espoirs et qui apprennent qu'ils
espèrent alimente en elle-même les
équipes évite donc ça veut dire que pour
vous c'est aussi l'occasion de faire
parler du club de montigny-le-bretonneux
voilà aussi de promouvoir l'image du
club de l'image du rugby sur la commune
donc c'est une journée de fête c'est la
première fois que vous l'organiser ce
type de rendez vous on a déjà un an
dernier organisé un 16e de finale en
cadets alamercery qui est le plus haut
niveau
en moins de 17 entre donc massy et le
stade français est toujours au stade de
la couldre alors quel public vient
assister à ces matches les passionnés de
rugby
les parents des joueurs puisque l'année
dernière sur le match entre massy le
stade français en avaient dû atteindre à
peu près dans les 500 spectateurs
ah oui donc vous réussissez à faire
venir dans ma vie le monde sur ses
différentes rencontres dimanche ça
débutera avec les crabos donc les plus
jeunes
paris affronte lille d'ailleurs sur les
deux rencontres ce sont des rencontres
paris lille stade français lille lille
qui est 6e paris 4e après douze journées
de championnat cette victoire parisienne
trois victoires lilloises et parmi les
différents joueurs un joueur qui est
originaire du club de
montigny-le-bretonneux
oui mathieu du pif mathieu lépine qui
mettant au jour en juniors crabos
alors quel est son niveau réel justement
est-ce qu'il a une place importante dans
cette équipe puisque vous vous le suivez
un petit peu et garde des contacts aussi
avec le oui en fait son père est
toujours dirigeant au club et donc en
fait il est titulaire il est titulaire
en première ligne à peu près trop faible
et donc 80% des rencontres ça veut dire
que c'est une future vedette peut-être
parce qu'il paraît que au niveau
national c'est un petit peu compliqué on
va peut-être leur trouver dans l'équipe
nationale
alors à soa et après effectivement pour
les joueurs de première ligne c'est un
peu plus compliqué dans la mesure où
après les clubs pros font souvent appel
à des étrangers surtout le géorgien est
une denrée assez recherché si je puis
dire
peut-être que les choses vont évoluer au
fur à mesure du temps parce qu'on se
rend compte qu'il faut aussi apprendre
aux jeunes de rugby a évolué dans nos
championnats pour ensuite s'en sortir
bien puisqu'on le voit l'équipe de
france est en difficulté oui parce qu'en
fait la ligue nationale de rugby a
depuis maintenant deux saisons imposé
aussi ce qu'on appelle les joueurs issus
de la formation française le jsf est
donc dans les saisons à venir
les clubs seront tenus d'avoir les clubs
pros seront tenues avoir un certain
nombre de joueurs issus de cette
formation française pour revenir juste à
mathieu du pif ce sera l'occasion de le
découvrir a évolué avec ces jeunes à
partir de 13h30 à montigny le bretonneux
au stade de la couldre du côté du stade
français il a un vrai bon niveau oui
puisqu'en fait il faut savoir que pour
un jeune comme lui qui a commencé en
moins de
17 donc au stade français après basso -
19 il faut franchir un palier il faut
toutefois s'améliorer pour franchir ce
palier et le club de montigny est un
vrai club formateur
oui occasion d'en parler aussi vous
former des jeunes qui ensuite évolué
évolué par la suite ailleurs dans
d'autres
notre équipe après on a oui on a un
jeune au club qui a femmes à temps une
partie du blâme à 6 ans fait qu'ils
aient gavin gallinelli ce dont le père
et entraîneur à l'école de rugby et qui
fait partie du top 100 des moins de 17
ans et qui est au lycée au pôle espoirs
à lakanal donc si vous voulez voir les
futures vedettes des différents
championnats de rugby au niveau national
il faut vous rendre à montigny le
bretonneux le dimanche pardon dès 13h30
pour le match les reichel
ils vont jouer juste après lille
toujours face au stade français lille 7e
sur 8 parquet premier après douze
journées 10 victoires cette saison pour
les parisiens et une seule pour lille
alors là ça va être un match à sens
unique un oui c'est offensant reichel
oui parce qu'en fait les clubs de
fédérale une qui sont pas des clubs de
rugby pro comme le stade français sont
beaucoup plus de difficultés au niveau
reichel encore en crabos on arrive
peut-être un peu à équilibrer les choses
mais après en reichel c'est vrai que
l'écart se creuse plus fortement donc si
vous devez faire un pronostic sur ce
match la france que c'est le seul
français en plus les entraîneurs des
reichel du stade français ce sont des
amis voilà alors c'est un peu biaisé
comme pronostics
si vous demandez un autre pronostic pour
terminer france-ecosse 16 mars dernier
match du tournoi des six nations alors
je souris je ne devrais pas parce que la
france a toujours aucune victoire
lacoste est troisième je pense que toute
façon là ce sera pour moi un match à
quitte ou double 1 ou alors là où se
réveille ou vraiment part au fond du
trou on espère tout de même cette
victoire pour la france dans ce tournoi
des six nations et ce sera le samedi
soir si vous voulez suivre les grands
les seniors évoluent et nationales
internationales et puis le lendemain
vous irez à mon signe bretonneux voir
les différentes rencontres merci à vous
c'est moi
on reste dans le sport avant d'ouvrir la
page échos du jeudi avec ce reportage
consacré au roller hockey les chocs ce
d'elancourt qui réalise une bonne saison
en nationale 3 les joueurs sont
quasiment assurés d'atteindre les
playoffs
même s'il avait déjà assuré leur place
en playoffs avant cette 12e journée des
chocs continuent leur marche en avant
face aux ulis les élans portois cueillis
à froid leurs visiteurs en marquant deux
buts coup sur coup
dès les premières minutes de jeu
respectivement par ronan qu'au fond et
sébastien bach et les joueurs de
benjamin ferran sont meilleurs dans la
conservation du palais que leurs
adversaires et ajoute un troisième but
avant la fin de la première période
en seconde mi-temps les chocs se balader
sale l'addition en inscrivant cinq buts
de plus score final 8 boul avec cette
quatrième victoire consécutive les chocs
sont désormais deuxième de nationale 3
avec 21 points à trois longueurs du
leader caennais pour s'assurer un
premier match de classement plus
abordables les chocs vont devoir être
performant lors des deux dernières
journées de national troyes où ils
affronteront le leader camon et leurs
poursuivants directs aubergenville